in this morning's ion money millions of
Americans could receive smaller checks
after filing their 2018 tax returns the
average refund is down more than eight
percent compared to the same time last
year according to the IRS so to clear up
some of the confusion we're joined by
CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger on your book tour taking
some time off to come and help us make
sense of this Jill it is the first tax
season since the president's tax cuts
went into effect how is that impacting
refunds well so far and I just want to
say so far we are talking about one week
of data so let's be clear that a lot of
people were surprised at this first week
now we're expecting around 80% of
Americans will see lower taxes in 2018
than they did in 2017 the problem is
that many of those people may have
already gotten those refunds how through
their withholding and when employers
adjusted withholding people may have had
more money come to their bottom line
part of that was potentially your tax
savings so if you get a smaller refund
you may have missed the fact that you've
gotten a lot of it already the economic
hope was that if it's in your paycheck
earlier you'll spend it you'll save it
you'll do things with it instead of
having to wait for the refund if you're
confused about what's up with my
withholding what do you do well I think
the first thing is you want to see how
much was actually withheld from your
check and you get that from your tax
documents when you file you're gonna
have a better picture as to what you
need to do going forward and I think
this is incredibly important if you find
that you owe money you're going to have
to adjust your withholding tell your
employer hold back more money send it to
the government so I don't have to write
a check on the other hand if you're
getting a really fat refund then you may
want to adjust the with holding the
other way because really a refund I know
people think it's for savings but you've
just extended an interest-free loan to
Uncle Sam for the year and I got a
feeling you can use that money better
than your uncle yeah I saw an interview
with a guy who's very irate because he
said last year he got $10,000 back this
year he has to pay 10,000 is that all a
matter of withholding I think that
that's an extreme case and I don't think
we're gonna see as many stories you'll
hear about them I think those are people
who come from high tax states if they
were high
haxe if you're in a high-tech state like
New York New Jersey Connecticut
California your deductions for your
state and local taxes were limited to
ten thousand dollars those are the
people who are at risk about five
percent of taxpayers will likely pay
more this year than the previous year
and most of those folks I believe are
going to come from those high tax states
with limitations on their deductions it
doesn't feel like it's an extreme case
when it's you know so what should you do
if you haven't filed yet what should you
do okay so when you fire get money back
well I don't know if you have to get
more break even or we just get you to
file when you have it says please use
software and the IRS has free software
IRS free file if you make less than
sixty six thousand dollars this is the
vast majority of Americans almost
seventy percent can qualify for this try
that if you need help to programs that
are important Vita it's a Volunteer
Income Tax Assistance Program tax
counseling for the elderly go to irs.gov
there is a ton of information there file
electronically paper is so 1985 and a
ton of information from you as always
thank you Joe